thank you everyone we know people are
concerned they want to keep their
families and loved ones safe there's a
lot of bad information out there right
now and the CI DC just wants to issue
some basic common-sense guidelines that
everyone should follow during this
crisis number one
wash your hands with soap for at least
20 seconds coming up to the wrists
number two you just want to clean and
disinfect any frequently touch surfaces
or objects like countertops or doorknobs
number three if you do have to cough or
sneeze do it into a tissue and then
discard that tissue I don't know why
have to tell anybody that who keeps a
used Kleenex if you need to sneeze or
cough and don't have a tissue just try
to sneeze away from the people you're
with if you're surrounded by people I
don't I just try to sneeze towards
someone you don't like I'm just kidding
I know what you can do is you can sneeze
or cough into the crook of your elbow so
kind of like like that and that will
keep the germs from spreading don't
worry that was just a demonstration
don't touch your face
don't shake another person's hand don't
shake another person's face just in
general you want to avoid close contact
remember that expression I wouldn't
touch them with a 10-foot Pole you know
I know we've had that conversation Jill
so just think of it not a 10-foot Pole
it's a six-foot Pole and you don't want
to touch any weight with it or if you do
just make sure you disinfect that pole
when you're done you don't wanna be in
any large group so we recommend you
avoid any groups more than 500 people so
like a concert or a I'm sorry any groups
of larger than 200 people so if you see
more than 50 people don't go in that
group so it's okay 10 people so if you
know what just don't get any groups at
all if you see another person just run
the other way if you do go into a public
place like say a grocery store make sure
you buy at least two years worth of
toilet paper in general if the Shelf
looks empty there's only one or two
items left just buy them it doesn't
matter if you need them or not
it's also a great time to stock up on
those foods you're never gonna eat
anything that's shelf-stable you want to
keep in your bunker like Kansa lima
beans creamed corn
Vienna sausages canned okra hearts of
palm large containers of garlic salt any
of those are great options
obviously don't drink Corona beer I
think we all know that but even those
that keep those two exes or like the
skull of crossbones on a bottle of
poison and I've told that Modelo is the
Spanish word for death you want to stay
away from all Chinese products don't eat
Chinese food
remember the low main high risk you
don't want to play Chinese checkers
don't watch any Chinese films you know
that old expression Chinese fight
disease look at these there was some
misleading information about the film
parasite the Oscar winner this past year
that I would like to clear up you won't
catch anything from watching this film
in fact it's not even Chinese it's
Korean so that makes it one of the
safest films you can watch now there's a
side effect of this social distancing
we're all doing in a condition known as
cabin fever coincidentally another
oscar-winning film but this is in no way
related to the corona virus and there
are several ways you can combat this any
sort of social interaction you can do
with the people you're confined with
like playing games having a fun little
80s sing-along night so like you could
cheer yourself up by singing the song
come on Eileen to substitute the lyrics
covet 19 a second option suggested by
our staff is the song hey mickey so it
would go something like this
see Obie d-19 in our homes we are
confined hey sickie hey sicky hey that's
good see OVD won nine cause the markets
to decline hey sickie hey sicky you know
or just you know anything that's a fun
like that in short as Americans and you
know frankly as citizens of the world
the best advice we can give here at the
CITC
is that we all come together I mean not
literally I mean stay away from each
other but separately we can unite to
lick this coronavirus again not
literally
thank you and stay safe